good morning hey guys so I'm driving to
Barton Gio's house today is my day to
assist Bart so in case you guys didn't
know I'm actually part Joe a David
personal assistant and what that means
is I handle any errands that they need
me to handle so if they need to get
groceries or get their laundry done or
get their car washed
I'm their girl I got them so I think I
went full-time with JK once I got back
from Italy so for like about five months
I'd say I've been trying to get used to
this new lifestyle and you know meaning
not having a nine-to-five because I used
to work at a hospital and it's a lot
more liberating but it's a lot more work
back when I had a nine-to-five you know
only ten hours of my day where we're
taken up by that job but now that I
worked with Jake a full time and like
this just you know this freelance can
kind of lifestyle I guess I would call
it it has no schedule it's pretty much
24/7 so first thing I do in the morning
until the last thing I do at night I am
working and it's the constant work hold
on pull I was waiting for this car to go
anyways today is Friday and on Monday is
when we are all leaving to Hawaii for
bar congeals wedding which I'm so
excited for I've been uh you know
helping Jo planning for months now she's
actually pretty difficult when it comes
to her wedding because she's very both
of them they both really want a wedding
that's like super laid back they want
zero planning like zero traditional
wedding style right and that's awesome
that's really cool that they're like
that so laid-back
but as someone who's trying to help them
put it pull it together it's really hard
because it's like [ __ ] wait hold on
you don't want it traditionally than
what do you want and you don't want
nothing so it's gonna be nothing but do
I planned nothing then and that's gonna
be my Friday today I have a whole bunch
of errands to run
I just got a part in Gio's house so you
guys in a bit so I just finished up at
Barton jailhouse I did my duty then I
get him well that sounds kind of weird
but now I'm heading over to the Senate
made them all to meet up with Gio
she is currently bikini shopping for her
Becky and some inish join her because I
actually have a lot of errands to run at
the mall besides shoppings have a lot of
returns to make for Bart
and so you know kill two birds with one
stone I guess do run my errands and I
get to shop before bikinis for have
Mikey here comes to Yvonne manwë work a
girl but you get a bar one in four
shorts but
or shorts like these Nike fleece
disguise shorts I noticed that Oh Q you
actually have a shirt that matches it
sure yeah you have a shirt that kind of
looks pretty good and then I bought
smells because as Tiffany knows I always
pick grandma's smells so maybe later you
can approve these
like buy three get three free Oh tight
come up alright let's go shopping
now I'm in a car with Tommy and Cornelia
hello and we are headed to the 66 night
market and I'm so excited because I've
always wanted to go but I've never had
the chance to go because you know our
schedules didn't match up or what I
really reason I've never been able to
come and KP was supposed to come but
he's stuck at home editing trying to
finish up and edit and he's being
responsible so that means that today I
will be a third wheel oh come on no yeah
so excited to eat some good food guess
what guys Julie and I are twinsies kind
of
so now we both like kind of kind of did
we thanks work each others and wear the
same color but they were like pretty
dark shirts it looks different in the
camera boat this color is actually love
like closer than what it looks twinsies
I suck at countering is slow shaky
man people even act like in Asia here
they bump into everyone yep
yeah we came on a good day because urban
legend has it yeah
the lanes here are hella long so I'm
glad we came today
TJ's tacos liars just kidding I don't
know it could be really long
good
and then you get a ring cool
Oh
yeah
first first meal
you guys like
experience is to go through anyone
thank you
I got the duck
do they have hot cheetos on this [ __ ]
hot cheetos Oh
since I got a is an octopus ball
is different sounds making it is a
Japanese dish
you heard that time on JK news and we
started talking about the yeah
under what the takoyaki is tonight
you're gonna get them
learning camera movements from Tommy PC
like that cinematic oh that's nice
I like that zoomin
it's foggy
they're actually like
pretty good boy yeah
maybe later I find it really funny how
you call me to this like 66 night market
which is predominantly like I am I think
that you're both interested in is
non-agent Asia must be locals it's like
a Mexican thing it's really bomb which I
might get later and then I'll show you
guys I supposed to go really me penis
shaped ice cream cone we are about to
eat eat Julie and I are sharing tell me
one three
penis shape I should
we talked about this on JK news
it's pretty addicting oh [ __ ] that rhyme
haha we got
we've been wanting one of these for
everybody
he's tying the shape
I pictured the tip to be longer but
don't be like that
you'll find how it really is like your
people kind of stuff
my people
Tostitos right there yeah chips they are
tips
oh you'll see when they come back Oh our
old school take his kids back in the day
oh no I can't do that right now
we've got to try our luck right now
right now go yeah look at that you
improve oh my god
[ __ ] time cuz that's how the Mexicans do
it my favorite oh oh and then there's
time oi this
correct
and you can't have it without Eileen
you keep mixing oh yeah
and pork skin which in Spanish we call
the world
I'll try posted person
here's a question while I'm psyching
Valentina there's a lot but bad [ __ ]
Hungary tips let me eat this myself it's
easily my favourite Ginny's like candy
oh you like candy I can see why you by
yourself I got it I want it pretty good
really good
I told you guys my people oh was it
going I'm on a sodium alright guys so
we're back at the car
yup calling it a night so it was so fun
thanks for letting me tag along and be a
third wheel
Oh problem even a third wheel to begin
yeah I didn't know is there boy I don't
know we were second willing you know
yeah guys it was so fun this is the
first time let's get out huh sorry it
was the first time that I actually got
thinking I was coming to it just the
three of us and I loved it we need to do
it more often
yeah wait wait one two three Oh
Oh jimothy yes
so much I hope you guys enjoyed watching
my day today let me know what you guys
think of this vlog and make sure to give
it a big thumbs up because I need a
confidence booster for these vlogs
because I need the motivation to keep
going man I'm tired all right guys